this podcast is brought to you by on it
go to audit.com and look at the great
selection of supplements if you find
something you like pressing code Joey
and get 10 off delivered right to your
house what's happening you bad
[__] it's Monday October the
3rd it's sober October for some people
me I'm gonna take care of myself but I'm
gonna keep smoking dope as you know if
you want to feel better heart and sore I
want to welcome them to the podcast as
you know I've been eating healthy for
the past couple of years at least I try
but I've been also taking beef organ
supplements from heart and soil beef
organs are the most important nutrient
dense foods on the planet more than kale
spinach and blueberries combined that's
why they're called Nature's multivitamin
listen I felt great I've been trying the
warrior supplements my recovery's been
better I've been making some good gains
and our ancestors ain't organs for
thousands of years and never suffered
from obesity heart disease and
anti-immune issues of fertility because
they were eaten organs Nature's Most
treasured Foods founded by Dr saladino
heart and soul supplements are made from
grass-fed Finnish beef organs feel like
a man when you take supplements made
from liver heart kidney spleen and
testicles over in China they paid
Millions for this stuff to put in the
soup but right now you can have heart
and soul to help you reclaim your
Birthright to radical Health you
understand me go to Heart and Soul dot
coal again that's heart and soul dot Co
use code Joey 10 for 10 off your first
order that's heart and soil dot Co and
use code Joey 10. offer applies to
one-time purchases not subscriptions
tell them today and see how you feel
they try them today and see how you feel
and like I said to you you're gonna feel
great
it's so broctober [__] the joint
is also brought to you by DraftKings
Sportsbook an official sports betting
partner of the NFL was a tremendous
weekend of football and tonight we got
the Niners against the Rams there's a
tremendous [__] game let's get this
party started right now we're talking
touchdowns tackles big plays helmets
flying and even bigger wins new
customers can bet just five dollars on
any NFL team to win and you're gonna get
203 bets everyone can boost their
winnings with DraftKings stepped up same
game parlays I love same game parlays
the more legs you had the more Giddish
you win and to make things even sweeter
you can throw down with the stepped up
game parlays once per day all season
long just download the DraftKings
Sportsbook app today use promo code Joey
to get you 200 and free bets if your
team wins when you place a five dollar
bet on on any football game that's code
Joey only at DraftKings Sportsbook an
official sports betting part of the NFL
minimum age and eligibility restrictions
apply see show notes for details
DraftKings download it now and then go
win some [__] money let's get
this party started on a Monday morning I
miss you guys
check one two welcome to Uncle Joe is
joy
[Music]
foreign
what's happening you bad [__]
it's Monday the 3rd of October can you
[__] believe
it's [__] October already October
October like it's Halloween I mean
listen I went somewhere last week with
my daughter and I already saw Christmas
[__] out
yeah Target like there is Christmas [__]
out usually you gotta wait till like
[__] the day after Thanksgiving or
while you're watching the football games
on Thanksgiving they're not waiting for
dick I mean Halloween [__] was out right
when [__] school started I've been
seeing spooky [__] and skeletons and
stuff so these [__] are not
stopping Jack but it's a beautiful day
to be alive we got a whole new [__]
weekend it was raining all weekend in
Jersey like a [__] the tail end
of the hurricane my heart goes out to
all those people in Florida who are
[__] swimming around canoes right now
what a [__] nightmare that is Fort
Myers is wiped out I mean the
florentines lost their [__] uh they
have like a pool little house where you
hang out while you're in the pool what
do they call it was a cabana the [__]
thing got ripped right the [__] off last
night we went into the city or Saturday
night and we were coming back
and on the Subaru it kept saying high
wind advisory high wind advisor I'm like
what the [__] there's no wind out
Sunday morning when I woke up guys I
have a little table outside with a
little umbrella you go out there and
write jokes and stupidity
I asked my wife what happened to the
[__] table the table was gone and the
umbrella holy [__] I was out Sunday
morning 8 30 in the morning in the car
looking for the [__] umbrella all
over the neighborhood not a thing so
that's just to let you know the wins we
got in Jersey Saturday night I can't
imagine
what the [__] was going on in [__]
Florida and it's like you know I mean
when I was a kid we got hit with the
1991 and it used to be like every seven
years in Florida every eight years now
it's like every [__] four years
somebody's getting hit it's either them
uh New Orleans you know [__] Georgia
it's uh you know I don't know what
they're talking about with climate
control and all this [__] but it doesn't
take a genius to let you know yeah it
doesn't take a genius to let you know
shit's changing man for example when I
moved to [__] Jersey
I got here in August I was prepared to
sweat my [__] balls off
nothing there was no [__] humility
you know when I was a kid living in
north in Jersey [__] once May started
once Memorial Day ended you walked
around this [__] town sweating that's
all you did that that's the reason why I
[__] left I I hated humidity when we
moved back here I go you know what
I'm a big boy now I have to deal with
the humidity there hasn't been any
[__] humidity I remember some is in
Jersey like a week in July where you
can't [__] sleep you just don't sleep
with the air conditioners going the fans
going you're naked you know the beds
you're down to one sheet you don't sleep
because the [__] humidity won't let
you [__] sleep I remember trying to
do Coke and [__] the coke would
dissolve in front of you or when you
went to cut a line out the whole stack
would move with you because the humidity
would get into the [__] cocaine it
affected everything my hair do the smell
of my [__] because the [__] it's
just terrible so I know that this summer
we had what two weeks of humidity Maybe
I didn't feel it it was like yeah it's
humid out whatever but when I was a kid
here you couldn't [__] walk around in
the Summers so I know something's going
on I don't know you know I'm no
scientist I don't know nothing about
Dick you know but
my heart goes out to the Florida people
that's all I wanted to say I know it's
[__] tough you know I read some of
the [__] from Cuba these [__]
have no food they lost their electricity
and the refrigerator all the food went
bad there's no milk for babies so
it never [__] ends guys but I'm the
[__] good note it's a new month a new
week I'm excited for Saturday night show
number two we got Kim condom and uh
Sarah weinchak opening up for me I don't
know who else will drop in I think Lee's
gonna swing by my man Michael be there
so yeah it'll be a good time I'm excited
about that I've been writing a little
bit but I gotta talk to you guys about
something I saw this weekend
the importance about getting entertained
I grew up a [__] movie buff but I
grew up a movie buff to take me away
from what I was experiencing in my life
like when I went to a movie theater it
was just to disappear I went by myself
you know the the best movies I ever saw
were by myself and like we discussed
before I love every type of Cinema I
like every type of music I like all that
[__] but at the end of the day as human
beings we like getting entertained you
know
it's funny a couple weeks ago I don't
know if you guys follow them or whatever
it was tough not to uh our friend Rogan
went to uh he woke up one morning and he
got on a plane and went to Vegas and he
went to uh
the ADCC he went to the UFC and then
that night he went to the boxing match I
I didn't know I just the next day
everybody was saying and I talked to him
I called him like two days later and I
asked him
how did it feel to go you know because I
know it's different from he's been
telling me for years how he can't wait
to go to a fight as a spectator
like he's like you have no idea how bad
I'm waiting on but I got it's got to be
the right you know the right thing
I love being entertained I love all that
[__] when he told me that I was like I
told you man that sometimes you just
gotta sit on the other end and just
watch
just watch whether it's a baseball game
a [__] tennis game doesn't matter two
cockroaches wrestling it doesn't matter
it takes you away from your reality
and it opens up your mind a lot of times
I know for me like
if I see something different I'm like
wow that that was
not what I expected it's not what I
liked I don't like it too much but why
did he do that why did she do that in
the movie why so all this [__] when I
talked to him that day was like it was
just it was like an experience like for
us like for him it was an experience and
I'll tell you what what the problem is
that
a guy like Joe can't go to a [__]
movie theater
because four people while he's watching
the movie will come up to him we'll come
up to him in the [__] movie theater
and go excuse me we don't want to bother
you the opening fire excuse me we don't
want to bother you but we just wanted to
say hello during the [__] movie
whether it's a fight a movie a
restaurant it's very tough for that
gentleman for anybody you know when I go
to the movies that Ari in this city it's
like you know two guys will come away
man what's going on and we don't I don't
give a [__] but think about it it's
tough to get entertained when people are
bumping into you and [__] and asking you
[__] stupid questions or whatever so
that's why guys like Rogan Bert Reicher
you never see him anywhere you know the
last time I got entertained properly
was 2019 when I went with Bill Burr and
Josh and my wife to to see guns and Rose
at the Palladium and it was [__]
Sensational a little liquid IV to fuel
the [__] Monday mornings got second
you never know whatever you ate over the
weekend mushrooms Edibles I was just
talking to my man Mike and he's like nah
I want to eat two of those mushroom uh
mushroom gummies with no Edibles this
time I said no no no no no it's great
but let me tell you something the other
night in my highness I ate five of those
[__] gummies and four [__] ABX
Edibles guys I don't have to tell you
what [__] plan I was huh
it's so funny because I like those
mushrooms whenever I post them on
Twitter people lose their mind but
there's always the three Joe Rogan fans
excuse me if we're doing a psilocybin
make sure you shut the [__] up shut the
[__] up you know one oh two grams ain't
enough listen shut the [__] up there's
always people always got to say
something [__] stupid on that let me
tell you something you take four of
those mushroom gummies five of those
things and two of those abx's
oh
it's not gonna be here voices though I
had a bad experience about two or three
nights ago I could not [__] fall
asleep I ate like three of those
mushroom gummies late at night like 11
o'clock that was not [__] good
because I ate the gummies because I was
taming down the ABX Edibles see I
haven't eaten yeah I haven't eaten ABX
Edibles in like two weeks I ate those
little 350s from uh
the stonersclub.com
I like once a month I get the [__]
true dose gummies they're [__]
tremendous and the true dose chocolate
[__] the common Joys you'll be on a
different [__] planet and they also
have the the power whatever things that
are [__] deadly tremendous so I was
eating those for I alternate them you
got to Ultimate you got to take care of
your tolerance but this week I got back
into the ABX bag
with those [__] mushrooms those silly
mushrooms guys you don't know what
you're missing go online I don't have
the link but you have to go through a
vendor for those things that fifty
dollars a [__] bang but let me tell
you something they're well worth it guys
I don't like the taste of buck mushrooms
I got mushrooms and just thinking about
eating them none they're dry they taste
like [__] eating a splinter
thank you
but years ago
I was in a
I was in a writing wheel dog you're
always getting a writing rut
especially after you do a CD or you get
dump your material like when you dump
your 45 minutes you have to start again
and guys I don't you know it's hard to
do anything in life but if you have no
idea how hard it is
exactly you should a special
let's say like out of your 50 minutes
they cut a joke out so you get to keep
that one joke that's it
and you have to start over again that
first month is [__] brutal it's
brutal you're just going up the bomb and
you don't want to do all material you
want to put it behind you and start from
scratch that month is a [__]
nightmare
so you just gotta keep going up on stage
and talking [__] so you pick places that
nobody's going to see you and you just
make little [__] appearances and do
15 minutes whatever and look for another
hook you got to look for another hook
and once you have that one hook you'll
find that one night it's so weird you go
from having three minutes of material
and finding a hook and now you get up to
seven minutes of material so now for a
week you got to go out there do 15 20
minute spots with seven minutes of
material waiting for your next hook and
that'll take like another 10 [__]
days but once you have that that'll give
you that'll open up another [__]
relative material so all of a sudden you
went from seven minutes to 12 you're on
to something and so on and so forth but
sometimes your creativity is [__]
null and void you can't
you know and listen guys it's it's not
you're not going to just open up a
notebook and write a [__] uh you know
Eddie Murphy Delirious that's not gonna
happen it's gonna take [__] time it's
gonna take a few years you know I really
respect Anthony jeselnick Anthony
jeselnick told me something once
Anthony jesmond prepares his material
one year he does it in the comedy club
then for a year he takes that material
and he goes through a theater and he
sees how it works he makes changes and
then after that's that hour is tight
he'll [__] do a special
it takes Anthony jeselnick like two and
a half [__] years to put a special
together when most guys it takes a year
these guys are pumping Out specials
every 12 months every 14 months Anthony
Jeselnik hits [__] hard when he hits
he hits hard that [__] and I
look at that and I'm like that's a smart
way to do it but the agents A lot of
people are on Greed our own ego won't
set two and a half years I'm telling you
I've lived for years and when you're in
a comedy State of Mind trust me guys
you're churning out material everything
you see becomes a [__] joke right now
I'm halfway there where I'm still
cracking myself up once in a while and
that's how you get the party started but
sometimes guys you just cannot find that
creativity and I was stuck in like 2001
I wasn't doing CDs or anything I was
just stuck I was trying to get to that
place
and I asked one of the best greatest
writers of all time I saw him at the
store one night and I go Paul I pulled
Paul Mooney a sign I go Paul I got a
problem man
I'm having a hard time especially coming
down to a comedy store
and you know at The Comedy Store you
have sets every night some nights at
that time there was eight people some
nights there'd be 30 people
so I didn't really care about bombing as
much but it starts to concern you after
a while you're like what the [__] is
going on with me so I pulled them aside
like what do I do
do I start from scratch and he goes no
take a week off and go get entertained
go hit a few movies
go watch [__] you never dreamed of
watching
I go like what he goes I don't give a
[__]
Chinese gymnastics a ping pong
tournament
just find [__] that you could go sit
there and see people do something that
you're maybe not even interested in or
maybe you have a certain interest in
and see how [__] you know a band
I gotta tell you something whenever I
was stuck in Boulder when I was first
starting there was a place around the
corner from my house like an Australian
band an Australian man it was a
restaurant bar called like the Outback
and I used to go there on Mondays and
there was like a little room in the back
with like 15 people for comedy
but it was a recording studio
it was a little real really it really
was a little recording studio
so I asked the guy he goes ah Tuesdays
Wednesdays we do local bands here and I
can't remember the name of this band
they were like a [__] uh
what's that [__] they rap a little
bit they were like uh uh hello
nah they were more like uh you know the
Red Hot Chili Peppers jumping up and
down and hitting themselves each other
in the head and they were kind of now
I'm a comic
but I would go see these guys and two
days later I churn out five minutes of
[__] material you know now what does
a band have to do with me you know how
can I get creative from watching a band
you watch the singer I would watch the
singer when I would when I first started
comedy I would go to see these local
bands but I would focus on the singer
because they're just a conduit just like
me a singer is a [__] tough job
because you're a conduit
you're a condo from a band you're
you know the [__] trumpets behind you
the cowbells behind you the two guitars
behind you the drums are behind you you
know and there you're the [__]
spokesman for the [__] band so I've
always focused on singers like Rod
Stewart or I loved watching [__]
Robert Plant move his hips Elvis you
know that's part of the stand up is
watching a great singer sometimes
because he's doing the same thing you're
doing only without [__] music he's up
there so if you're studying to be an
actor a comic you can look at a [__]
singer from a good singer and finger and
it's not his voice
I don't want you to think you have to
sit there and look at his [__]
Madonna has a horrible [__] voice but
when she's on stage she's got great
presence
you know she's got great presence
presence is a lot of but that doesn't
matter right now but it's so weird how I
would go see a stupid band in 95 and it
would whatever so when Paul told me that
I thought about him like Paul that's
crazy you said that because when I lived
in Boulder my thing was to go see these
little [__] bands at this [__] uh
bar I forget what nights it was like
Wednesday night or some [__] like that
on the way home I would go in there and
just sit there and it was I forget the
name of the band who the [__] knows if
they're still together I don't know but
my point being is so
these uh last couple months I've been a
little bit on the creative side but it
wasn't like I was before the [__]
pandemic what's happening you bad
[__] this podcast is sponsored
by better help listen it's a Monday
morning I want to talk to you about
something sometimes you could fix it in
a problem for so long that you don't
take time to find the solution trust me
I do it all the time but when you learn
how to find your own solution there's no
better feeling a therapist can help you
become a better Problem Solver making it
easier to accomplish your goals listen
I've been with better help now for over
a year
and I tell you I feel a lot better the
most important thing I got I love the
live talk therapy but she also gave me
exercises to deal with my [__]
anxiety and all the things that you know
I I just I fixate on stuff and I can't
get it out of there but with better help
I've changed all that better help is
online therapy that offers video phone
and chat therapy sessions you can choose
not to see anyone on camera if you want
to but it's much more affordable and
in-person therapy and you're never going
to find a therapist now I could get you
a therapist within three days with
better help so when you want to be a
better problem solving take care of
yourself visit betterhelp.com
right now slash Diaz that's the code I'm
going to get you 10 off your first month
so visit
betterhealth.com
Diaz Diaz and I'm Gonna Get You ten
percent and I'll tell you what you're
going to feel a lot better and the
clarity is going to come to you back to
the show when you're you know when you
got like Tom Segura right now Tom
segurus and his comedy Glory he's got a
great hour he's about to put on tape but
he gets on stage every night
in front of a [__] theater never mind
that The Comedy Store Flappers or The
Improv and then on the weekends you're
getting on stage this guy's getting up
in front of average three thousand four
thousand people a night let me tell you
something if you sit with Tom in the car
right now in 20 minutes he could [__]
writing out because his mind is already
moving like I said before the pandemic
I was cracking myself up every [__]
five minutes because you're looking at
the world differently now I got this
fatherhood and I'm living in Jersey but
I'm starting to so this week I uh
Friday I had to go into the city to do a
table read wardrobe take a picture a
little [__] ugly kid you know because
he he's like my son in the in the pilot
you know that took that took a [__]
hour
so uh
I was like you know man I got the week
off and I talked to Chaz and Chaz uh
like two weeks ago we spoke about
something he goes hey man
there's tickets left if you want to come
to see my show on October 1st but
I thought about it I go where the [__]
is it and he told me it was at Town Hall
and I go that's interesting I didn't
even think about it like that so I think
Wednesday night when I found out my
schedule for the week because I was
hoping Mike would get married on a
Saturday that's why I left this weekend
open we didn't know then Mike got
married on a Friday
so our Saturday was wide open one of the
moms was having like a movie night
around the corner
she said you know you guys are invited
we said we'd like to we couldn't get a
babysitter for Friday and we couldn't
get a babysitter for Saturday
so uh she said just drop her off and
pick her up after the show so
we got tickets online I got two tickets
online
and Saturday night I took my wife out on
a [__] regular date you know just us
two just uh
and it was great went into the city it
was shitty weather so it wasn't like uh
when Mike and I went into the city
[__] him in September for that show that
was I saw people it took like an hour to
get out of the parking garage
you know it was a lot of people so I
wanted to show my wife the city hopping
but because of the rain and the wind a
lot of [__] people weren't out last
night so it took us you know whatever we
got I got to the theater about uh five
to eight and it was the Bronx Tale
and uh we had the last row on the bottom
level you know we walked in I didn't
even fit in my [__] chair
it was like sitting on a Frontier flight
I swear to God I had to put one leg
crooked and the one leg up and that
morning it was funny because that
morning I spoke to I was going to say
Ralphie I spoke to Ari
and Ari goes what are you doing so I go
you know what I got to go into the city
to watch
the Bronx Tale at uh town hall and he
goes that's crazy that you're going to
town hall you sold out that place twice
you looked that place on fire now you
get to sit on the opposite side and
watch what you were doing on stage I was
all in for last night I was excited
about last night I was gonna get to see
something new and different I have
always been a fan of the one-man show
guys as you guys don't know before the
pandemic I was working on a one-man
[__] show once a month at The Comedy
Store I would show up up there and just
talk about a time period in my life you
know
the first one-man show I ever saw was
Whoopi Goldberg's I got like a VHS tape
when I lived in bold when I started
getting into comedy in 92.
and I don't know if you guys have ever
seen a one-man show they really like I
could put on a good one-man show except
for one problem I can't do characters
I can't break down a bunch of [__]
characters first time I saw Whoopi
Goldberg's one-man show
my [__] head exploded my [__] head
exploded was it hilarious not really
they're not supposed to be hell I mean
it's always great if they are hilarious
a one-man show
but ours was funny she did every [__]
character from junkies to drug dealers
to hookers she [__] nailed it I was
like wow that that's like being a
one-man band you know
and then the second one I saw was like a
93 I saw one called spicorama it sounded
like azamo is [__] one-man show and
uh very interesting John has about 10 of
them but the spicarama one there was one
before speakarama spikarama was maybe 93
and I bought the book to it I had a
follow-through book
um and that one I didn't see live I had
a [__] rent it and watch it
but I was like wow that is just it's an
extension of a one-man show
so like when I did Ari's Storyteller
show they're a little piece of a one-man
show go up there and tell a story or
something that happened to you in a
funny manner you know make it sad pull
them out of the [__] sadness with
something funny and that's what a
one-man show does it goes through it's
like a it's like going to a regular play
you have uh your First Act your second
act and your third act and you got to
break them up that was the problem with
one my one-man show that I had done it
maybe six times and it will all our 15
hour and a half
and I still wasn't done so how the [__]
can you have a one-man show that's eight
hours what are you people gonna sit
there for eight hours and have a meal
with me so we either had to decide
whether to break it from
the point after my mother died or it
ends with my mother dying or it begins
with me coming out of prison and getting
into comedy so that was the [__]
thing we had and maybe sprinkling some
of the past in but we never got to that
part the pandemic hit to direct the [__]
and quit The Comedy Store and life moved
the [__] on so
when I had the opportunity to see chaz's
I had never saw chassis I saw the film a
few times you know it's on every other
[__] week but I never got to see the
one-man show
when they offered me
the residency in New York City they said
basically you could do whatever the [__]
you want then
you can do whatever you want you could
do an hour of stand up you could do a
one-man show now for you guys who know
me
and know what I think is important in
life
do you know how happy I would be if I
could do a one-man show on Broadway
do you have any [__] idea whether it
was good or bad do you have and I mean I
would try to make it as good as I
possibly could I wouldn't make you come
down and see a bum rap but do you know
what it would mean to me it would be
[__] uh
it would be superb man a one-man show on
[__] Broadway I catch a little heat
but that's a complete different story
yeah so I went over there Saturday night
and
I didn't know what to expect you know I
walked in with my wife we sat in the
[__] Southwest tickets in the
southwest seats
foreign
but here's the [__] funny thing that
our seats were just the way the theater
was and how old it got
our seats just got to come back and then
we had two people in front of us and
they were right there guys they were
right [__] that I could smell the
guy's [__] neck
so what we did was as soon as the lights
turned off we just got up and we moved
to because a couple seats in the back
row will open and then we had more room
it was just that area that the [__]
seats were combined them but I gotta
tell you man I don't know how old Chaz
Batman Terry is and it doesn't matter to
me I know he's a little older than me
he came out [__] guns blazing
he was so [__] good
you know I spoke to him Sunday morning
he thanked me for coming to the show and
I he goes what did you think
I go listen man you knocked it out of
the park but what really had me [__]
cooking was the stage presence he just
[__]
you know man
and that's what you see singers do like
when you see the singer from Rage
Against the Machine that [__] on
the stage
you know Robert Plant on the [__]
stage like that guy really owned the
[__] stage Chaz last night
[__] owned the stage he came out I
mean just firing everything I mean there
was no backdrop because I guess the
theater was too big to have like a
backdrop but he had Sirens he had smoke
he had gunshots he had people yelling he
had music Doo-wop music Dion and the
Belmonts I mean it was it was a one-man
[__] show
I sat there and [__] all and it's the
same thing you saw in the movie only a
little bit more explained he explained
the the African-American girl he was
dating he explained the characters he
does every [__] character
I mean beautifully and there's got to be
20 [__] characters in the thing he
talked about his dad he talked about his
mom
it was just uh
it went by fast
it was like I sat down and I didn't even
go get a bottle of water I was when I
sat down I go [__] I'm gonna go with a
drink for me and my wife we didn't say
boo throughout the [__] whole hour
it's like an hour and a half we did not
say boo not even a [__] nothing we
just weren't all we would look at each
other every couple minutes and go wow
[__] this guy's got it down and then
the highlight of the night was some guy
heckled him
some guy [__] act with him and he was
telling the part
where the dice came he was talking about
the dice game and how
you know uh yeah all that [__] he's
talking about the dice and and uh mosh
and all this and he was doing more she
was doing Frankie coffee cake I mean he
was doing all their voices and stuff it
was just brilliant guys all of a sudden
he's talking about that he has to shoot
Dice and he goes yeah
collateral throw whatever uh you know
14.
he goes lucky 14 and some guy yelled in
the audience 15 and Chaz just [__]
stopped the one-man show and he goes I
know I'm in [__] New York there's
always got to be one knucklehead so he
was throwing people into the bathroom
and uh in the [__] scene and he goes
get the [__] up and get the [__] into
the bathroom like with the rest of the
guys like he didn't move he didn't pull
out a character he didn't pull out a
character guys which I thought was
[__] just tremendous the place went
crazy because that's what people want to
see people want you to react to
Something in the audience if a waitress
spills her drinks that's why I tell
people don't focus on the words too much
when you go up on stage and you got that
set list when you're a young comic don't
focus on the words
I want you to know bullet points and
where you are that's the most important
thing because if this waitress or if
this [__] knucklehead gets up and
slips on his head you have to say
something and then come right back to
where the [__] you were just to really
keep the worst is making a tremendous
joke and then come back and now you
don't know where you are so for you
going away and you'll do this as a comic
once or twice this is how you learn to
be a place because you'll have a great
five minutes and then try to go back to
your material and now your material
cannot follow the event that just
happened in the room it is just it's you
know comedy 101 guys so
we watched it he took us uh it was an
hour 45 on the DOT that's as
professional as can be
an hour 45 isn't too long
and it isn't too short it's just [__]
right
so I made a mental note if you're gonna
do a one-man show keep it at 145. 145
everybody's [__] happy I can't stand
when people do two three hours I don't
have that type of [__] uh I can't sit
there for three hours if Jesus was there
talking [__] I can't sit there for
[__] three hours so and I love Jesus
you know we all love Jesus if he shows
up right we all love Jesus right we
don't love G we don't love Jesus right
so
he was [__] great uh
you know we got we got a standing
ovation I got up
and uh he had a q a
but we had an hour drive home and uh
we just wanted to get out of the city
so we just slipped out the [__] back
door we caught an Uber went to the ferry
and uh we took the one of the ferries
back
I love taking that [__] furry the
wheel I love all that [__]
on the way up we stopped at Rudy's we
got a little [__] uh gamar with some
[__] Rhode Island uh clam chowder
delicious they just put the red and the
white and mix it they caught a royal
Island I guess that's what they [__]
do and it was just a great night guys my
wife had a great night
I had a great night and I came home
and I watched the Moon is with my
daughter and stuff and she went to bed
and boom
the creativity from the one-man show
just kicked in I mean while I was
watching The Honeymooners of my daughter
it was already like [__] like things
you know I've got like I would lose
place like you I was watching it and
then two minutes later I go what the
[__] just happened because my mind was
already [__] cooking once she went
upstairs I was tired and I sat down and
made a few mental notes just you know
jokes a couple things I saw with his
one-man show and
on the way up the stairs I like this
[__] really works and when I got up
this morning that's you know I got up
this morning I made a few notes before I
went looking for my [__] umbrella
yesterday morning after the one-man show
I got up in the morning and I couldn't
wait to come home and sit and it just
gives you different ideas you know
I love to watch movies guys and a lot of
you people are going to be mad at me for
what I'm about to say
I tried watching Top Gun last week
I didn't even try holy [__] that was bad
and guys I know a lot of years are gonna
attack me and say Joey you're wrong I'm
a Tom Cruise [__] the only
reason why I didn't join Scientology is
because I'm not gay yeah I got nothing
to hide you know what I'm saying I've
already told you all my sins
so uh I love Tom Cruise I watch anything
Tom Cruise is in Interview with the
Vampire I [__] love them okay
collateral the the Jake whatever movies
where he plays that secret agent what's
his name Jack breacher I love all his
[__] okay the movie he did with it as
the Colombian [__] drug dealer he did
that movie as a pilot that he played the
redneck with the blonde the cute blonde
I love [__] Tom Cruise but that
movie and listen I watch it with my wife
my wife is his is as white as can be and
she'll check me she'll go Joey you're
too high this movie's great I asked her
at the at the hour of March I go Terry
what's going on here she's like
I have no [__] idea
I go this is not good but then she goes
what do you want to do you want to stop
like oh no
let's watch it we pay five bucks for it
on [__] Amazon Prime let's watch the
[__] let's watch another half hour
I saw Val kilma with the scarf I'll kill
him listen Val kilma
Val Kilmer
acted without saying a word and he did a
better job acting than all those [__]
young guys [__] didn't say a
[__] words out camera and he was way
better than that teller guy with the
mustache that drove me [__] crazy and
the other pretty blonde that was talking
[__] that dude and what bothered me the
most about that movie is that young kids
have seen that [__] thinking that's how
you act let me tell you something you
act as creepy as that blonde dude or
Miles Teller and somebody's gonna bust
your [__] head because that blonde
guy that's all he needs is a good smack
to the face you grab him by the throat
and say shut the [__] up pilot boy I'm
the Captain Kirk of this [__]
Enterprise and that pen teller with that
[__] I don't know what's going on with
these people that think they look cool
with these creepy [__] mustache you
look like a professional [__] you
look like a professional [__] sucker
with that [__] mustache the 70s are
gone you stupid [__] everybody's
talking about then after I turn the
[__] time gun we put on that [__]
Blondie [__] that [__] oh my God that
was bad that was really [__] bad I
mean we lost we were like turn off the
TV I'm exercising this [__]
television they got bad [__] TV that
that but I'll tell you what was good
though that [__] Dharma [__] white
people are losing their [__] mind I
watched the whole [__] thing I didn't
remember this you know people already
talking [__] the story wasn't true but
but listen
Damu was real contractor I remember
going up there six years after that and
doing that uh Club in Green Bay maybe
whatever the [__] it is not Green Bay
Milwaukee I did that club in Milwaukee
and one of the guys at the bar the
janitor dude I don't know if he's a Jen
like a maintenance guy
I was like how far did Jeffrey Dahmer
live from here dog it was like giving
that [__] a line of coke he
didn't shut up for two hours he started
telling me [__] stories about bars and
places that because a bunch of [__] came
out I guess after he [__] died but
that TV show is [__] Buck Wild if you
haven't seen Dharma and [__] I
mean this guy was doing some creepy
creepy [__] I guess the building got
knocked down but Jimmy Florentine said
he went to the dama hotel where he used
to take those guys a [__] uh give him
pills and the [__] he would dose
those [__] but listen all those
little young [__] creepy kids say he
[__] killed I gotta tell you
something they would pray for me to do
some because whatever the [__] he was
dosing them with was killing those he
was trying to make human [__] zombies
that's what he said the first time
like would I be making it [__] happen
on a Monday morning [__] vitamins
minerals hard on juice in there
everything is in there but no
I watched that [__] uh Dharma and it
blew me the [__] away and I liked how
they shot it they showed you what he did
then they tell you the [__] story so
now you know if you got a creepy kid
that's [__]
yeah his parents were [__] up but you
know what man I mean
you can't blame everything on the
[__] parents yeah when you have a
child like that I mean even their
parents are in Shock sometimes I mean
you never you know you never know what
the [__] the kids are thinking
are doing I mean listen man my mother
wasn't involved in my life
I wanted it to be even while she was
alive I had a mom that really trusted me
and she didn't look through my [__] you
know I was like pretty [__] cool
and as a parent I don't want to look
through my daughter's [__] and get on a
computer and see what the [__] she's
doing but you gotta have a grasp
and I got to tell you something
if your kid is [__] creepy
you should know it like if your kid is
[__] creepy
you should [__] know it you know this
kid his mom was a whack job the dad
taught him how to open up animals and
when the debt but when the dad taught
him how to open up animals
it was something innocent it was like a
project like going to biology class and
opening up a frog at least that's how I
saw it maybe you guys didn't see it that
way
about to get to pick up and get [__]
uh [__] from them what do you call those
animals or the road roadkill come on
guys but that's a that takes a different
uh
animal you know Hey listen you hear all
these things about when I was a kid if
you want me to be [__] strictly
honest with you I think I threw some
[__] rocks at some cats you know when
you're a kid like you if the the animal
I ate at the most were [__] flies
I hate flies when it comes to flies I am
not a Cuban Buddhist you know me I
[__] you know the other day by
mistake I hit a [__] squirrel you
know those [__] things that get stuck
in the street and they try to go
backwards and throw and I thought I
passed them also like and I looked back
and I saw his tail and I had to pull
over and say a [__] prayer that's a
little animal I didn't mean to do it
when people start killing cats and
that's that's a [__] problem and
listen if you do it one time
like I had a friend who once told me he
[__] threw a rock at a dog and
because I felt so bad after that I was
six years old I get it I get it you're a
[__] kid when I was a kid I took a
piece of metal one time and hit my dog
in the head with like a I had my mother
had a French poodle on 88th and when we
lived on 89th Street and
I don't like French poodle she used to
bite me and [__] so I remember one time
I had it with a pipe it wasn't even a
pipe it was one of my drum kits it held
like the snare drum and I'll never
forget I was gonna [__] burn it with
the pipe so I took the pipe and I put it
over fire
like an idiot that I was at six and not
realizing that the [__] heat was
going to come up to my hand
so I'm hoping I'm gonna burn the cat or
the dog what the [__] I was gonna do and
I just lifted and I got blisters on my
hand and I never [__] burnt the dog
thank God but I I think I hit the dog
with a pipe one time my mother nearly
[__] killed me but that wasn't that
didn't warrant it
like that that was never my you know I
killed flies I [__] hate flies one of
my friends Dean lepreet told me once
that he saw me kill like 30 flies one
day and take the Wings off all of them
and put lighter fluid on them and light
them up so I I forgot all about that but
it sounds like something I would do you
know
but uh listen you can't look at your
child and predict the [__] future
you know you just can't you know when
when I was watching that Escobar thing
when he gets killed the mother's on the
bus
and it comes over the radio that Pablo
Escobar got killed you know and
people were clapping and she was like
all heartbroken when she went to the
body she was telling them she goes you
know people said my son did all these as
a parent we don't even believe it we
live in so much denial of our kids you
know that we have to see it like we have
to so instead of [__] not paying
attention to your kids because you don't
want to know the truth you it's like
anything else
you know we don't want to know something
we won't pay attention to it as human
beings like we don't we don't want to
know what the [__] is going on in there
you know something's wrong in that you
know that this isn't [__] right so
I enjoyed the Dharma uh I'm not a psycho
I just enjoyed it again as entertainment
guys
oh the guy that played Dharma That's my
boy that dude was on a show called mayor
of each town
he was the cop that got shot in the head
that was the good-looking guy that was
taking her out to dinner and [__]
yeah he's an American Horror Story
listen there's nothing better than
watching
good acting good writing
script you know
I mean I don't need it all to be an
Academy Award I just want to be
entertained when I watch TV
or when I go to a movie I wanna you know
when you watch a Jerry brookheimer film
like Jerry Bruckheimer is all over
[__] CBS right he pretty much owns
CBS
so when you watch a Top Gun
it looks like you're watching
CSI like one of that especially that
they use lenses and [__] to make it look
like the movie in the 80s
and they really tried and I'll tell you
something else I didn't like about that
movie you ready guys
it
a Mexican pilot a Top Gun
no
I never saw a Mexican pilot in one of
those Top Gun movies it they had to be
what's happening you have to put
everybody in the movie when you have to
put blacks and Chinese diversity
diversity is coming to [__] films now
you know and again the world is changing
entertainment's changing everything is
changing I'm not ready for it to be that
diverse yet you got to sell me on it
first you know I was waiting for a
transgender pilot to walk out anytime I
really [__] was I really was I'm like
wow this is Jerry Bruckheimer this is
CBS look what he's doing already in film
like I understand television with
sponsors and stuff like that but if
you're already doing it and film
we're going into a different [__]
Direction here but Hey listen like I
said whether it's a one-man show it's a
movie or whatever
you gotta get really entertained from
time to time and I know it's rough I
know it's it's rough to look at concert
tickets and go [__] 200 to see my
favorite [__] band
you know and but guys every once in a
while I want you to take your favorite
favorite favorite favorite band and
figure out how to go see them was
somebody new you know somebody you've
never [__] seen before I just heard
something the other day that and they're
not even advertising it
B-52s are doing their last tour it is
completely
sold the [__] out like completely sold
out I like the early B-52s the first two
albums when they had the heroin guitar
player that died he had a different
[__] Dimension to him I mean that
guy's great the first time rock lobster
and the second one uh my private Idaho I
think it is I'm not sure [__] he he
destroyed the guitar I don't know if I'd
go see him now but there's a lot of good
shows you know for me I want I'm gonna
start going to see more plays
um
I don't know what plays I'm gonna try to
look at like Off-Broadway like things
that I like I like to see things in the
beginning
you know I like to see the work I like I
don't mind getting a couple tickets like
one in September one in December and one
in March to see the progression of it
you learn from that you know really
interesting it's like there's one band
that I wasn't a fan of a huge fan of
this I was a fandom when they came out
and then as they got bigger over the
years I definitely became a huge fan of
them I've seen them maybe one time and
uh
but it's really weird I'll close with
this it's really weird when you hear
them and the band I'm talking about is
Motley Crew you know when you put on uh
you know
what's that coming home whatever that
song is or about it
all those jams are [__] great but if
you really want to learn something from
Motley Crue put on that first out
sounds like they taped it in a [__]
closet
what's that first Jam Live Wire
it comes out all the time and I listen
to it it's not the best song in the
world but if you listen to Live Wire
from the first time I think the second
album has looks a kill on it right I
think I don't know the whole I when it
looks like kill came on every time I
heard that song I snorted a line of coke
that's how much I like that [__] song
she's got [__] it that the jam on that
is tremendous but when you listen to the
first album
and you see where they went like five
years later you're blown the [__] away
by them first of all he's a horrible
singer he was a horrible singer at the
end and he was even worse in the
beginning he sounds like a [__] Mouse
he sounds like a female he sounds like a
male Madonna on the first album so next
time you hear Motley Crue on the first
album put on Madonna's first album and
you go [__] they sound like mices you
know I mean that was the but you could
see that growth you could see how they
improved you could see all these things
and it just [__] blows you away so
that's why
I think I'm going to start going to
theaters in New York like Off Broadway
or [__] Broadway like they got Kinky
Boots it's backing off Broadway that's a
good movie I was thinking of going to
see that but who the [__] knows I'll get
AIDS just sitting in a movie theater
with my [__] luck well monkey pox or
whatever the [__] is going around
but that's it and that's that
[__] it's a Monday [__]
morning listen man if you're in a
sometimes you're in a [__] uh you
know it's not working for you maybe you
it's just time to get [__] to go out
and see something completely different I
remember a couple years ago I went to
see that Chinese [__] the Chinese true
Peng lay that they do the [__]
dragons and stuff I took my daughter it
was tremendous it was you know and as
and people were like he went to see that
Julie you only type that would go to see
that I go to see anything to learn
something
just to learn something new that's how
you learn is by watching other
performers that are better than you you
have to just bite the bullet and go
sometimes and go wow you know what man
when I was thinking about quitting
comedy in 2009 2010
2011 when the podcast started taking off
I didn't know if I was gonna go back on
the road
for a year for a year
I went to the Irvine Improv every
Thursday night
every Thursday
didn't say anything to anybody I smoked
a joint in the car on the way there I'd
call the manager tell him to let me into
the back door and I'd sit there and I
watched every [__] headliner
from uh match uh and my favorite one out
of all of them that year was Greg
Giraldo you know I watched Ralphie I
watched Greg Geraldo I watched Bill Burr
you know their hour not that 20 minute
spots in the in The Comedy Store at a
club their full hour and man that I
[__] learned just sitting there
watching a real [__] headliner just
lay it down and
I'm not gonna tell you I brought a
little pad with me and I would make
little notes that the headliners would
do and I learned more in that year from
focusing on Thursday night just watching
Atlanta that I didn't probably my whole
20 years of watching stand-up comedy so
from time to time go out there go see
somebody who's better than you
[__] I love you stay black have a
great Monday
and after you [__] Thursday this
week because I'm shooting Tuesday and
Wednesday so what this week we'll have
the Thursday morning podcast I love you
[__] and now for a word for my
sponsors Jack
all right you bad [__] the
joint is brought to you by heart and
soil listen
you know I've been eating healthy for
the last few years or at least I try to
I've been taking this beef organ
supplements from heart in the soil
feeling a lot better I got more energy
and I'm recuperating a lot better beef
organs are what most nutrient dense
foods on this planet more than kale
spinach and blueberries combined that's
why they're called Nature's multivitamin
listen I've been taking these for two
weeks and I feel great I've tried the
whole package I'm taking the warrior
supplements and they're fantastic you
know who's got something to do with this
company Mr George Saint Pierre our
ancestors ate organs for thousands of
years and never suffered from what was
suffering from today obesity heart
disease and the immune issues this was
founded by Dr Paul saladino heart and
soul supplements are made from grass-fed
finished beef organs feel like a man
when you take supplements made with
liver heart kidney spleen and testicles
those testicles taste good so go to
heart and soul.com they can help you
reclaim your Birthright the radical
Health go to Heart and Soul dot Co and
use code Joey 10 for 10 off your first
order
that's heart and soul dot Co and use
code joey10 or for applies to one-time
purchases not subscriptions try them
today and you're going to feel like a
[__] Savage like the liver King the
joint is also brought to you by better
help listen
this whole last couple years has put a
big strain on the system it's with a big
strain on us and how do I know because
I've had my issues but when I was ready
I went to better help better help is
online therapy that offers video phone
and chat therapy sessions I've been with
Dana for about a year and a half and I
feel Tip Top Magoo a therapist can help
you become a better Problem Solver make
it easier to accomplish your goals you
can choose not to see somebody on camera
or see somebody and it's much more
affordable than in person therapy not to
mention better help will have a
therapist for you within 48 hours all
right so when you want to be a better
problem shop when you want to be a
better person when you want to feel
better go to betterhelp.com right now
pressing slash code Diaz Diaz and I'm
Gonna Get You 10 off your first month
that's called Diaz I'm Gonna Get You 10
off your first month
betterhelp.com DS the joint is also
brought to you by the king's DraftKings
I love these [__] what they do
now is tremendous whether it's college
football pro football baseball World
Series it's October baby we're going
into the baseball playoffs straight into
the World Series the NFL is [__] on
top of things and so is DraftKings
listen for the football for tonight
do me a favor new customers just bet
five dollars on any NFL team to win and
win either Los Angeles or San Francisco
come in you win everyone can boost their
winnings with DraftKings stepped up
parlays I love them the more legs you
you bet the more money you win and to
make things sweeter you can bet one
stepped up game parlay per day all
season long but it starts with you
downloading the DraftKings Sportsbook
app now use promo code Joey to get 200
and free bets if your team wins when you
place a five dollar bet on any football
team that's go Joey only at DraftKings
Sportsbook an official sports betting
part of the NFL minimum age and
eligibility restrictions apply see show
notes for details now download the
DraftKings app and go win some money
[__] I want to thank DraftKings
better help and heart and soul have a
great Monday have a great week and I'll
see you [__] suck this Thursday stay
black
[Music]